someone's having a birthday Prince
George turned seven on July 22nd and the
Duke and Duchess of Cambridge just
shared two adorable new photos in his
honor food group secret an amazing
ability to tell a story from toddling
around and enjoying butterflies with his
mom and dad at the Natural History
Museum during what was his first
birthday photo shoot - the toothy photos
mama Kate Middleton snapped ahead of his
sixth birthday we've watched George grow
up before our eyes prior to last year
the eldest Cambridge always posed for an
official photographer ahead of his big
day but it seems like he's officially
taken over having also snapped George's
seventh birthday pics earlier this month
but I'm very much
it's none known all the way in May the
38 year old Duchess appeared on ITV's
this morning to encourage UK residents
to put their own cameras to use for her
hold still initiative aimed at capturing
the country's mood during the global
pandemic William and Kate really to be
the frontline Royals in this national
emergency it's really been charming to
see them also include their children of
course Keith's been doing an excellent
job of documenting her own family of
five while they've been quarantined at
their Anmer Hall residents in Norfolk
England William and Kate will be doing
what every parent is trying to do right
now giving their children a sense of
stability and normality and trying to
keep as much routine as possible here
are the suite photos the Duchess snapped
in honor of her hubby Prince William's
38th birthday in June Kate also captured
these heartwarming images of daughter
Charlotte delivering food packages to
locals in need ahead of her fifth
birthday without fish property it was
possible shouldn't you try to have a
story and that's really what we hope
people will take inspiration through
this project but the photo she snapped
for Louise 2nd birthday are by far our
favourites
Keith's Instagram versus reality shots
are so hashtag
relatable I should have taken his
photograph of what I I look like doing
it of course the last few months have
been anything but fun and games for
everyone it's really it is difficult
it's hard to explain to you know five in
a sixteen eighty seven year olds what's
going on in make eight revealed this
about homeschooling her oldest son
during the Cova thank teen pandemic
George gets very upset he just wants to
do Phillips sure but it's project site
making so despite a sandwich it's as
[ __ ] bencher just yes and speaking of
making things last year caped old TV
chef Mary berry about her sweet birthday
tradition for the kids
I loved making the Kate has become a bit
of a tradition that I sort of stay up
until midnight with ridiculous amounts
of sort of cake mix and icing I make
fasciae more actually much I love it
[Music]